hi I'm Heidi Pratt Montag Spencer
William Pratt the other was fighting and
we're doing cancel our key factions of
2000 trends and fashion and at we're
from the hills new beginnings all right
yo tracksuit track suits are popping
right now I still have my juicy track
suits I love them on my homemade black
tracksuit when the hell's aired I didn't
have enough money for a track suit
how much weird track suits 104 top and
everybody dies of wine flat iron hair
I feel like always keep flat iron hair
everyone still does it hot irons great
it's easy fashion sexy sleek always deep
leather in here
okay I think I have to keep it because
clearly if I cancel it we're gonna have
issues I'm so thin eyebrows I would
actually argue that Elsie's eyebrows
right there are not actually pencil thin
I personally like a little bit thicker
of an eyebrow and to be honest I feel
like very thick eyebrows are very
fashion right now we shouldn't just
cancel I would call that crystal try
daddy style that boho is always in I
feel like it's almost a staple in
fashion it's always gonna come in and
out maybe hearts are gonna different yes
yes you Spencer oh I would also
acknowledge that I was way ahead of like
Miley Cyrus who currently is wearing
lots of rings
lots of necklaces it's very on-trend
this what is this 2008 Pratt daddy was
out here just iced out your welcome
Miley it looks great on YouTube totally
share my Pratt daddy style we can call
it boho oh whatever
I'm gonna keep it a hundo wide belts I
love white belt I think I'd like it more
if it was on this gif of this blonde
girl
that's her well you might not recognize
her because she's different color hair
now and it's shortly but this is Whitney
and she's actually on some of the new
episodes of hills oh this is actually
one of my favorite of her looks because
I think it's classic it's cute it's chic
I'm canceling it headbands um and I
think it depends on the person and where
this I'm just gonna cancel this a
headbands cool like in the gym if you
have a sweat or you're going to a music
festival and you're just doing it like
any character but like you walk in a
coffee shop without a headband I like
that are you Rambo get out of here
chunky highlights
okay this photo of Nicole Richie's
amazing I feel like this was so a moment
in time of like who she was when she was
like when she is fine some might call it
ombre now this is very chunky highlights
that's totally highlighted no one big
chunk yeah I won big trench on my
workout brimmed beanie this is so much
fun we should play these games Robin is
that what we call us I thought those are
calling schoolboys Newsies Rosie my
favorite look they cancel yeah that's a
cancer gene capris I'm gonna cancel it
that's maybe it's not I don't think that
ever started I hope that you need to
start okay I had a pair of jean capris
in middle school okay hey they were very
California result okay canceled again
sidekicks and flip phones oh no that's
not like an iPad keep it we'll keep it
you look so cute eggs I love us and my
masseuse controversial why you gotta say
like I love vegan everything but we
can't is big
watch out I don't know what she's saying
don't come from me I'm cancelling it
because it's I heard this there's a lot
of JAMA times oh my gosh this should
have been headbands that man's just
popping and we didn't watch the hills
back then I think we missed these two
are just our sisters should hang out my
again I'm baked hands I'd say keep
because they've evolved also and they're
not like as orange so I would say
frosted tips I'm gonna say we're
bringing them back season two you won't
even recognize me I'm gonna get pencil
thin eyebrows and I'm getting a
prostitute Tucker hi trucker but Tucker
my friend did where uh I don't like this
particular photo but I love trucker hats
and I know you're like they're not ones
you get out of a truck gas station I do
have one I loved from a truck gas
station that's canceled I just got a
Gucci trucker hat and the front is
leather and it says coochie and then the
back is like mesh checker that we're
keeping this basic surf shop gas station
no no so that's like a you need a
middle-sized that is never went out they
never will I just bought the biggest
pair I've ever owned they're also Gucci
they can be any and you say wow fedoras
I feel like those are also always gonna
be in because they're classic in what
city you're hanging out in I would think
it's safe in LA New York London I'm not
sure you know if you're gonna be fitting
in and Texas I don't know whatever we
just we were there I didn't see anything
Dora's over there
so we can't say anything okay barrel
curls I feel like are in maybe not this
particular photo or style there like a
little untaxed but brushed out like
barrel curls they're elected from the
recollection regulation I had some
champagne already was she finished there
Elsie with her curls is their start
lower
we're not canceling that no belly shirts
Heidi is just moved on from sure she
just wears her bra now on snapchat which
shot recently
we're gonna go bra shopping because my I
saw it snap I was like you have some
big-ass bras honey we need to get on
Rodale get into the Perla who bought
your bras all right so we're keeping
bellies hurts
skinny scarfs I love all scarfs I don't
think there's a wrong scarf so I would
definitely say keep it um bondage
dresses I'm so we're calling our class
sexy dress yeah I love it
oh my god so make sure to share this all
over social just like maybe even say
this too as a bookmark and the hills on
Monday nights on MTV it's the best on
television I like my evolution I can go
to find that you know I started shopping
at thrift stores and where I came from
and making more of my own style and then
being able to afford some more stuff
I appreciate the looks that I did have
and then where I could go with it and I
think it's fun it's like a fun flashback
for me I canceled everything about my
crystals everything else by is
embarrassed I can't even see any frames
like great crystals but oh my god your
hair your facial hair your outfits your
shoes or my dog credit card I'm not
gonna criticize myself like Spencer and
we can do this every week if you really
show engagement and Buzz he wants to
bring us back so please help us this is
the type of dig we'd love doing
you